Hello Freak bitches.
Well hiking on antelope island one time and uh,
just north of Utah and then they have this big buffalo reserve out there.
It's like a public peak,
probably 6,000 a day height and uh,
but there's all these free range in buffalo or were on the island,
you know,
and it's coming back down the hill.
Me and my buddy and as we were hiking down a trail,
you know,
about 300 yards down,
I can see there's a couple of buffalo right on,
right on the trail,
on the footpath.
And we're like,
eh,
sorry,
they'll,
they'll be moved on by the time we get there and we come down the hill,
come around this big boulder and sure as shit,
they're still standing there.
And I,
you know,
my uncle had a farm,
he had cows.
I never been around a damn buffalo.
I don't know the difference in a suddenly,
well they'll move.
It's just a big ass cow,
you know,
so we just keep walking towards him.
But if he jumps up on a rock and he's just laughing at me like a dumb ass
because I'm standing there at this point,
this thing is 15 feet and it was grazing like sideways with his hip towards me
and he's just eating.
And finally he looks up and turns his head and looked at me,
man.
And I realized holy shit was like the size of a Volkswagen beetle man.
Oh my God.
He's just looking at me.
I'm thinking this is some dumb shit.
Like,
what am I doing?
You know,
what do I do?
And that's a different buffalo buddy.
That's a water buffaloes,
animals school.
There you go.
Top lives.
Bison.
Yeah.
He just turns and looks at me and I'm like,
I'm so fucked.
And uh,
I didn't know what else to do.
That thing took one more step forward.
You did towards him.
I didn't know what else to do.
Mix.
We're looking at,
we,
we're making it,
you know,
I just kinda like took.
I didn't know like he's going to charge me,
I'm eating,
running or what.
So I took one more step and you just kinda like often and him and his buddy ran,
but when he started running me like the whole ground shook and I remember
standing there looking at my friend thinking like that could've been really bad,
but it's.
But it's open to the public and out there all the time.
It's buffalo everywhere.
So how's that?
A winning combination.
I like it.
I do.
I like it way better than I liked the idea of nature at your own risk.
Thanks for introducing me to your dog because I have to tell you that that video
of you grabbing that raccoon and chucking it down the stairs was easily one of
the most gangster things I've ever seen.
That lets you do.
Is this it?
I had to put a little disclaimer up here so that you know,
the animal rights folks wouldn't get pissed off.
Yeah.
That's.
They're going to get pissed off right now.
I hear him crying because there's no audio in the cameras,
but he's like,
just getting mauled by this thing and you just picked it up and fucking chucked
it.
Like gangster dude.
I mean,
you didn't just push it away,
you picked it up over your head,
went back behind the head like you're throwing a medicine ball because another
angle.
Yeah,
this is the best tag over the back of the head.
And Bang,
we're talking to Kevin rose,
the founder of dig.
I,
I gotta say though it was a little liquid courage.
I'd had a couple glasses of wine and number two,
my intention was to go down there and just kick it.
Right.
But it was on top of my dog so I'd be punting my dog at the same time.
It was tangled is.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you know,
then I grabbed it and it's,
it's greasy and kind of bristly so,
but you know,
whatever,
it's kind of,
it's when it's your baby.
I know it sounds weird to say with the dog,
but it's just like I thought he was dying.
He was getting,
he was howling like he was getting shredded.
But with this clause,
you know,
so I'm thinking my dog is being killed.
Did you think it was a coyote?
No.
You know,
we had seen raccoons in the backyard before and it was just one of those things
where they always just kind of like run away the second that the lights come on
and this time I don't know what he was.
I don't know if he had babies.
Actually there were some other records that we saw with him at the same time.
So I don't know,
man,
those weird sort of a fringe wildlife creatures like raccoons and coyotes and
kind of hang around.
Cities are so creepy.
Yeah,
there's a ton in San Francisco.
It's just all over the place at night.
They just dig through the trash.
Basically.
A
friend of mine was living out with the Navajos to kind of get his head straight.
Okay.
And he would,
um,
help take care of their animals when they,
this male female shamans both would go off to do pod ceremonies.
Oh Wow.
And he stayed out there for about a year and he kind of put himself together and
they said,
what helped you and we're interested in what your medicine is.
And he said it was Mtma.
And they said,
well,
we'd be interested in trying to experience Mtma.
So I was invited out there and we ended up doing this ceremony in a Navajo and
they only spoke Navajo.
They didn't speak English at all.
And there was this,
like in the western movies,
there was a trail of dust coming in.
Somebody came on horseback to be our translator and it was their friends,
it was their 17 year old niece,
holy Shit.
And she came
to mediate during this mtv experience and it became clear that this was really
for her,
not so much for them to,
for,
for them to show their seventh year who was torn between the different cultures,
that that's something about our culture.
We wanted what they had or was,
we saw it and respected it.
Wow.
And the,
and a lot happened in and in the,
it was wonderful in all different ways and there are some important healings.
But in the morning,
um,
when we were going,
this young woman,
uh,
was going to get back on her horse and she had 17 magazine.
Whoa.
And was reading it.
And that's where I started out that,
you know,
even out on the reservation in these protected cultures that had this
globalization of ideas and Internet and vodcasts and people are being exposed to
ideas that they wouldn't have normally been exposed to.
Even in China.
I mean,
they're having to do so much just kind of sensor stuff.